[Music]
jonathan's with us
in houston texas hey jonathan welcome to
the ramsay show
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
i want to know how you handle family
members
in an estate situation i'm over the
estate my sister's over
overseas my mom's finances but every
month at the end of the month she's
basically drained down my mom's social
security check
i'm sorry how are you over there oh your
mom's still alive
yes i'm still alive my dad died recently
and left the estate
to my mom i'm the trustee she's a
beneficiary
okay so how is your sister over the
money if you're the trustee of the
estate and all
the money is in your control this
the money that my sister is dealing with
is my mom's social security money that's
coming in
well that's all i'm only o yes my lawyer
says that
i'm only over the estate i'm not over
the social security right that's true
you don't have control of that okay and
so
your sister is using up your mom's only
money to live on
yes she doesn't have a job hasn't had a
job in several years still lives at home
wow and how old is she
about 42. okay
and how's your mom 72 with alzheimer's
oh wait is she um
is she still is she lost her capacity
no not yet she's still
functioning day to day um but she lost
her decision-making ability
no when you ask her direct questions she
can definitely answer that but
if you leave with something that's
open-ended she will ramble on and kind
of
drift off okay so let me tell you uh
i mean you can go as hard on this as you
want to go one is you can just let this
run its course and not worry about it
and you just make sure your mom's taken
care of
because soon enough your sister's gonna
have nothing when your mom passes
correct she's going to be out on her own
she's going to figure it out then that's
going to happen soon enough
uh if you want to go harder on it you
can sit down face to face with your
sister and say listen
here's what's coming when mom's gone
you're going to be out you'll get your
share of the inheritance
because that's what the will says and i
will abide by the will but you're not
going to be here anymore
you're not going to be done i'm sorry
i've done sit downs with their
over four times my friends have told her
some of the things i told her and she
still doesn't listen
okay she just keeps on going and the
only other thing you can do
if you want to go hard and i don't think
i would recommend this
but um you would have to have your mom
declared incompetent
and have the court apport appoint what's
called a guardian at light on someone to
watch over your mom
which would likely be you at which point
you would evict your sister
that's pretty hardcore your mom's not
going to enjoy that process
your sister's not going to enjoy that
process therefore you're not going to
enjoy that process
and truthfully i mean what's your mom's
life expectancy do you think
five years four years three years five
years
i'm i'm giving it i mean you know we're
current condition right now
yeah it's pretty easy to say five years
probably
or less yeah issues yeah i'm not medical
but i mean you've got you've got
a medium level of all summers and so
it's always debilitating so i don't know
anything about it i've just worked with
enough of these situations looking in
from the outside
so i mean it's up to you do you want to
let this so
i i you don't need the social security
money it doesn't
do anything for you it just aggravates
you that your sister's a parasite
because i'm i'm trying to make sure that
i paid off
all my debts once my dad passed away i
made sure that all the investments are
up to snuff
so that my mom will have if she needs
any assisted living nursing home
anything like that there's
money there to take care of her for five
six seven years
but my sister doesn't understand that
like we need an emergency fund i saved
up a lot of money
and bought a new washer dryer because it
went out of the house because my sister
didn't have the money saved up
and i tell her these things and try to
explain it to her and nothing gets
through here and i'm just wondering like
what i would do is sooner rather than
later i would get your mom
in a different situation for care
and just sell the house
you're in charge of the house are you
not yes yeah
okay so when your mom doesn't need to
live there anymore and needs care
i would get her in an assisted living
situation even if it's a nice high-end
you know partially functional but then
just tell your sisters you know you have
to move because the house has been sold
and that that gets her that may not get
her out of the social security but gets
her out of everything else
yes and it gives her the wake-up call
that bless her heart
at 42 she needs because she's not
productive she's not happy she's
miserable
every day every day i told her she's
miserable
there's no dignity in the way she's
living it's not fun for her either it's
just sad
but the problem is she's got some kind
of mental thing going where she's in
denial about
what her life's gonna look like so i
really wouldn't i can't recommend you go
hardcore on it but if you want to you'd
be understandable
that you did but i i think um you know
just
but please don't continue to expect your
sister to change ever
she's not gonna change all that's gonna
happen is she's just gonna become
homeless
and then she's gonna change but you're
not gonna change her you're not gonna
talk her out of this
i'm sorry that's so painful